in münster people walk and cycle
everywhere this city might look historic
but in many ways it's also looking
forward co2 emissions have been
radically reduced here 10 years ago
Minster decided to close down its
coal-fired power station
the former plant is now quite literally
green 10 years after the phase-out of
coal-fired power the city is now also
decided to take its pension funds for
civil servants which were invested in
the coal industry and invest them
elsewhere the name of the game
divestment the investment initially
involves looking at financial
investments to see if they fulfil
sustainability criteria those might be
ecological criteria but they might also
be social criteria or criteria that
equates to good business management in
the broadest sense these two students
define divestment in rather more radical
terms they're the ones who put the
municipal authorities onto the idea it's
removing money from coal oil and gas the
two young women are part of a global
campaign that seeks to encourage public
and publicly minded organizations to
switch investments away from companies
linked to fossil fuels
Winston is the first German city to take
this step the activists tell city
authorities universities and foundations
about ways they can help stop climate
change many of the people that we speak
to are not aware that fossil fuel
commodities are no longer profitable and
the first argument that we encounter is
always a financial one
people say that they will take a big
loss if they withdraw their investments
but the executives in minsters municipal
authority have known for years that you
can make profits by investing in
sustainable energy rather than fossil
fuels they parted company with German
energy giant RWE years ago we started
out on this path in 2009 that's when we
sold our shares in our w/e a long time
before other local authorities began
selling their shares we were partly
motivated by financial reasons but also
by ecological ones you buddy activate
Edna Savi but that doesn't mean that
Minster is fossil free the coal bunker
at the former coal-fired power station
was converted to store waste heat from
electricity production electricity
produced by a gas-fired power plant but
the city is nonetheless managed to cut
carbon dioxide emissions in half their
local authority says that it can't
completely do without gas still the
city's treasurer's are surprised that
divestment is quite a simple process all
it requires is a chat with your fund
manager of course sometimes were
informed that we might incur higher
investment scheme fees or the like
problematic influence in the cities but
no one's informed us yet that it's not
possible so basically all cities could
follow suit yes